c'est une expo à peu près une fois par
an den expo ici à la favorite date de 10
à 5 ans non en fait
j'expose généralement une fois pas je
présente les hommes puisque comme je
produis beaucoup j'ai une production
assez importante
donc les tableaux qui sont ici présents
ce sont des dernières heures les thèmes
sont les thèmes du pays c'est à dire je
suis dans la racine mans du pays
donc ça peut être sous le thème de
lavandières ça peut être le thème de la
motion de pistage d'aiguillés etc
c'est le thème de la vie de tous les
jours parce que l'on ne parle vraiment
valablement que de ce que l'on connaît
mais c'est vrai que parfois je
souhaitais obtenez par l'actualité
mais je sais j'essaye j'ai vite devant
détroit en prise avec cette actualité
j'essaie d'avoir un peu de distance mais
c'est vrai que parfois je
je donne libre cours au traitement de
cette actualité
mais mon production personnelle c'est
l'avis de la martinique
je vais pas vous cacher que j'ai changé
un petit peu ma palette
je suis parti vers des tons beaucoup
plus chaud et j'aimerais avoir la
réaction du public parce que c'est vrai
comme on connaissait surtout dans la
figure et actions avec les femmes les
visages du tout et cette fois ci je
représente disons les deux tiers de ma
production ce sont des toiles abstraites
voilà donc pour moi c'est une nouveauté
d'avant cette appréciation en faites
[Musique]
alors donc le vernissage
c'est ce soir et j'ouvre au public n'a
pas pu venir puisque comme si des souris
nous avons certains contes et légendes
de nombre de personnalités 1 recevoir on
peut parier que cette volée de demain
pour permettre aux gens qui n'étaient
pas bien une sage de venir voir cette
exposition dans la journée de vendredi
et j'ai 2010 mort samedi